do you believe in our ability to
leverage science in the sense that
there's all of these new technological
[Music]
methodologies that exist including fMRI
EEG EKGs the samples of the microbiome
do you believe in our ability to have a
biometric correlate to a non dual state
of awareness
what would a biometric corrala look like
yeah yeah so it would be something like
a like for example with brain it would
be like a connectome harmonic and so
that would be like the total of all of
your chemo electro connectomics are in a
harmonic state of resonance maybe with
your heart it would be that you have a
higher heart rate variability versus a
lower heart rate variability for
something that's more stressed in that
sense so there are these biomarkers for
cortisol are there these biomarkers for
for four more blissful or meditative or
peaceful states of consciousness states
of awareness so do you see science
potentially helping with a with a
biometric correlate of a more awakened
aware enlighten states of being science
may discover correlates that indicate
the ones state of mind but whether they
will help whether those discoveries will
actually help in the recognition we're
speaking of I I'm not so sure it's if
you were so optimistic or no no I am
very
optimistic I just I just don't feel that
that these correlates that scientists
may or may not find in the brain aren't
helpful either as indicators or more
importantly as means to the recognition
of our true nature if we look if we want
some measure of the indication of some
measure of our establishment in our true
nature I'm not sure that looking at a
brain scan is the place to look we
should look to the extent to which we
are at peace and happy for no reason
that would be a better test
imperturbable peace yes and causeless
joy
ooh imperturbable peace and causeless
joy adore that yeah no this to recognize
the nature of our selfie is is so simple
and it's been mystified yeah and
complexified and and obscured not by the
founders of the great religious and
spiritual traditions but by their
followers who did not understand or only
partially understood their teaching or
all that is necessary to go back to them
beginning about conversation is is this
metaphorical undressing this this
removing it's not even necessary to
remove thoughts feelings activities and
relationships all it's in other words
it's not necessary to change our
experience or manipulated in any way all
that is necessary is to see that element
of our self which cannot be taken away
from us to see that which is essential
to us not our thoughts not our feelings
sensations perceptions activities
relationships all of these appear and
disappear on the screen of awareness but
the awareness is that the essential and
irreducible nature of ourselves and did
this is
something that is simple everyone can
recognize it simply by virtue of the
fact that everyone is aware and everyone
could can simply it's not as I said it's
not necessary to reject the content of
experience all that is necessary is to
relax the focus of our attention from
its content yeah and just just relax
bank into the fact of being aware which
is that the ever-present and inherently
peaceful background of all experience
that's all and to begin with that this
background of awareness it seems to be a
place that we visit from time to time
and then we get lost in the content of
experience again but in time it ceases
that the back and forth between the
background of awareness and the
foreground of experience ceases and we
begin to be what Krishna Menon called we
begin to be established in our true
nature we cease just a visit from time
to time the piece of the background we
we live there we abide there we still
face experience we still have to deal
with our our everyday experience but
everything we think and feel and in time
our subsequent activities and
relationships are informed by and are an
expression of this background of of
peace and unconditional yes I love that
always a work in progress in the sense
of always becoming more and more
established and I think that's that's
that's very important in in making it
easier for people to feel like it's not
a far-off thing yeah yeah is it not a
far-off thing our being is is closer to
us than our most intimate and precious
feelings it is not even close to us it
it is us yeah yeah and getting getting
our entire world on that closer closer
closer and hopefully we have been over
time getting time
getting closer and closer to that and
then and then being your unique artistry
from that is I think the the general
essence of where we got in in much of
this yes yes all of us who are
interested in these matters you and I
and all your viewers and your express
our understanding such as it is in a way
that is unique to us you know I do it
through speaking and writing I used to
do it in my my studio but there are so
many ways
so maybe really a mini way some of them
require a lot of form a lot of content
they involve speaking or writing or or
your lovely drawing some other people
may not express this understanding in
form that they may just abide rest yeah
being and that they they're the ones
that that communicate that this
understandings silently yes I'm sure
that we all know yes what it's like to
to be in the company of someone who is
at ease who is at peace yes anything
irrespective of how wealthy or
impoverished they may be how powerful it
is to be in the company of such a person
and how when we go home we feel somehow
blessed just by being with them we may
have chatted about the weather or
politics or dinner or we may not have
spoken directly about these matters as
you and I have done there and they made
such people may never speak directly
about these matters but they communicate
this understanding silently and and and
that their communication their
contribution
to humanity is just as valuable as those
of us that yes express this
understanding in more formalized ways
let's thank you and as as we say in in
music what makes music music is the
silence between the notes yes yeah yeah
yeah